you know there are times when i
provoke the ire of the left and wind up
trending on social media and generating
negative headlines because i've said
something that they find offensive about
an important cultural topic
and then there are times when i provoke
the ire of the left and wind up trending
on social media and generating negative
headlines because
i advocated for a scientifically
accurate mermaid with translucent skin
now this latest outrage falls into that
second and admittedly very specific
category so those who listen to the show
yesterday may recall the very brief
moment during the comment section
segment of the show when i responded to
someone who was giving their opinion on
the black little mermaid issue in my
response i asserted that scientifically
it makes no sense for ariel to have dark
skin in fact i suggested that she ought
to be translucent and skeletal and
horrifying like a real deep sea fish
our loyal fans over at media matters
heard those remarks as they hear
literally everything else i say because
they're obsessed with me and want to
date me
and they immediately posted it to
twitter and published an article on
their site with the headline
daily wire host says it is unscientific
to cast a black person as a mermaid
other left-wing blogs picked it up like
the site alternet which reports and i'll
read a little bit of that report because
i think it fairly captures what actually
happened uh quote
right-wing daily wire podcaster matt
walsh threw a fit on wednesday over the
new live-action remake of the classic
disney film the little mermaid because
the main character ariel is portrayed by
actress halle bailey who is black matt
said that while he is sympathetic to
more racial inclusion in fictional works
he opposes bailly's casting because of
marine biology quoting me now quote also
by the way with the little mermaid can
we also just mention that from a
scientific perspective it doesn't make a
lot of sense to have someone with darker
skin who lives deep in the ocean walsh
complained i mean if anything not only
should little mermaid be pale she should
actually be translucent he continued if
you look at deep sea creatures they're
like translucent they have no
pigmentation whatsoever and they're just
these horrifying they look like
skeletons floating around in the ocean
that's what the little mermaid should
look like she should be totally pale and
skeletal where you can see her skull
through her face walsh noted adding that
this would be a version of the little
mermaid that i would watch
now that is indeed an accurate and full
quote which i do appreciate mediamatters
on twitter provided the full video but
they were more selective in their
caption so jason campbell campbell
tweeted the video but the caption was
just daily wire host says it's
unscientific to cast a black person as a
mermaid
now
uh which again is what i said but then
didn't go further with the uh with the
rest of it
from there it was sort of off to the
races my statements calling for a
translucent mermaid were picked up by
other media outlets like newsweek they
had a headline about it it even went all
the way across the world the sydney
morning herald in australia was
reporting on reporters started emailing
me asking for comment on the issue which
i was more than happy to provide by the
way
leftists across the nation expressed
their outrage i was one of the top
trending topics on twitter all night and
still today because of this my allegedly
racist
translucent supremacist views ignited a
national
firestorm now just reading through a few
of these angry tweets just for fun um
one says wait wait wait first these
fools want to say that science doesn't
matter when it comes to vaccines and the
like but then want to be science
guardians about fictional creatures josh
marshall of the talking points memo
tweeted i shouldn't laugh because the
racism isn't funny but they struggle to
present their racism as scientific have
you ever even met a fish
he actually wrote that have you met any
fish they don't look like people with a
few exceptions they're not white what an
effing clown
another tweet says quite possibly the
strangest thing about self-described
theocratic fascist matt walsh's argument
for why scientifically a mermaid
couldn't be black is the fact that it's
just wrong he's confusing tanning
changing someone's skin tone to the
amount of melanin in someone's skin
another one says attention matt walsh f
your scientific perspective mermaids
aren't real just say you're a racist and
take up significantly less air time buy
and there's this there are a lot of
extraordinarily dumb and pathetic
racists in the world but matt walsh puts
them all to shame with pearl clutching
cakes like this another from a woman
named victoria brownworth who bills
herself
as an award-winning journalist says
quote wait matt walsh says there's
science behind his racist take on the
little mermaid casting is someone gonna
break it to him that mermaids are
mythical creatures and disney makes
animated features for kids
now there are many thousands more where
those came from ted liu got in on the
dog pile so did cnn correspondent john
harwood many others conservative
masochist and [ __ ] david french joined
in
the outrage reached into unexpected
corners the media liaison for the
portland police department
for some reason
sent me hate mail about this calling me
garbage for my comments about a
translucent mermaid this guy's name by
the way is david singer and we'll put
his message up on the screen
incidentally in the message that i'm
putting up on the screen you can see his
email address there which is a shame i
wish we could
block that out or something but i forgot
to and now it's out there you can all
see it please don't email him though i'm
not asking you to do that anyway he was
hired by the portland maine police
department during the defund the police
hysteria as one of the three civilian
liaisons and his job which he has paid a
salary by the taxpayers for is to
facilitate community and media relations
and this is his media
outreach strategy evidently a very
interesting approach to say the least he
actually sent me that bit of hate mail
called me garbage and then blocked me so
that i couldn't respond this is media
outreach okay this is what the portland
police department in maine needs
all told
the left was very upset
about my push for greater translucent
representation in mermaid casting and
let me just say to begin with
that i am glad the left has chosen to
take my comments seriously
i was of course being totally serious
when i made them i am not one to joke
i would never engage in something as
juvenile as sarcasm
when i say something as my audience
knows it means that i am 100 sincere all
the time and i especially would never
joke about an issue as serious
as translucent representation in
hollywood so the three points i want to
make here
first of all
i have long been an advocate for the
translucent population a fighter for
trans rights you might say translucent
individuals have been marginalized for
far too long and now even film roles
that rightfully belong to them have been
appropriated i ask you when was the last
time you saw a skeletal translucent
goblin-like monstrosity cast in any
movie
now granted we have one as a speaker of
the house right now but that is hardly
enough
if they will not earn roles in films
about deep sea creatures who sing
then what hope do they have
translucent people exist and they
deserve to be affirmed translucent
rights are human rights translucent
lives matter
second
many on the left have sent me messages
or left comments insisting that my
mermaid racial theories are factually
incorrect they have presented many
arguments seeking to debunk my thesis a
journalist named there are a lot of
journalists by the way who are chiming
in on this and there's a journalist
named catherine marshall she sent a
whole string of tweets fact-checking my
alleged misinformation
and insisting that mermaids are more
like seals who breathe air at the
surface that's what she said and as she
reminded me indignantly
seals are black
but this argument fails because mermaids
live on the ocean floor and as you may
recall in the original film ariel's
trips to the surface are a source of
great controversy in the mermaid
community they don't want her to go
there at all this means that mermaids do
not need to surface in order to breathe
air as seals do no living on the ocean
floor with flounders and evil octopuses
clearly qualifies her as a deep sea
creature
she certainly lives deep enough where
there wouldn't be nearly enough light
penetration to necessitate high
concentrations of melanin in the skin
indeed the lack of light penetration
would create as i argued a translucent
appearance this would be both
evolutionary an evolutionary adaptation
allowing for greater camouflage from
predators and a logical result of the
lack of sunlight so
do your mermaid research before you try
to engage with me on this subject you
need to bring mermaid facts and mermaid
logic to this conversation
by the way
i demand this level of accuracy out of
every disney film it's one of the
reasons i've always objected to beauty
and the beast for one thing the story
promotes bestiality as beauty begins to
fall in love with what is essentially
a large talking buffalo
for another the servants who turned into
household objects and pieces of
furniture would in reality be so
psychologically devastated by this
transformation they'd be in no mood to
perform song and dance numbers for the
beast female prisoners
not to mention they wouldn't have vocal
cords or a musculoskeletal system that
could facilitate that sort of physical
movement
third and final point
i am
the beloved and revered lgbt author
of johnny the walrus
i literally wrote a book about marine
animals johnny the walrus is not just a
masterpiece of children's literature but
also
the seminal scientific treatise on the
subject of aquatic mammals
so those who are questioning my
statements
are therefore not only engaging in
homophobia and gay erasure
but also are refusing to listen to
and trust the experts
this is dangerous and toxic behavior not
to mention an example of stochastic
terrorism
as an expert in the field
and as an advocate for the translucent
community
i will not allow myself
to be silenced or marginalized
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated